so we have a new talking point
about coronavirus vaccines that is
getting
oxygen and the talking point is these
are not vaccines they are and then you
can kind of choose your own adventure
they aren't vaccines
they are dna modifiers they aren't
vaccines
they are gene therapies genetic
therapies and there's a few other
versions of it
and it's actually been around for some
time but it's now catching on more and
more
let's listen to former trump adviser
and breitbart propagandist stephen
bannon
making this claim on his show
some kind of show that he has let's take
a listen to this actual conversation
and debate these are not technically
vaccines
right the first ones are they're
experimental gene therapies
every scientist i've talked to admits
that and and here
why can't you even i'm not an
anti-vaxxer i we're the ones and
look at this show is specialized in
whether you think it's a bio weapon
from the wuhan lab that either they let
out on purpose or
inadvertently escaped or if you think
it's a total hoax
so steve bannon there also actually gets
into the entire
the virus is a bio weapon stuff
but i mean you know we can't do
everything in one clip let's focus on
what he said about
vaccines because it's more relevant
whether or not you believe the virus is
a bio weapon
i don't think that impacts your interest
in a vaccine if you believe that the
vaccines aren't really vaccines that
might actually
impact whether you want a vaccine so
let's focus on that steve bannon says
these are not technically vaccines they
are
experimental gene therapies and this has
been floating around
and the kernel of this where does this
come from
the kernel is that with a so-called
normal vaccine or so-called real vaccine
the body is developing immunity on the
basis of
a deactivated or weakened virus that is
in the vaccine
and that is what generates the immune
response now these
mrna vaccines messenger rna vaccines
they don't contain deactivated virus
but they contain sequenced
virus and instructions that
they say quote modify your dna that's
the talking point
it's a dna modification but let's go
piece by piece
first of all steve says it's
experimental what does he mean by that i
don't know
mrna vaccine research has been going on
for decades
they've been studied for flu zika
rabies and cmv vaccination so
experimental
not really it's been it's been studied
for decades second
and this is probably the key part the
mrna vaccine
contains instructions for your body to
make
the spike protein that the coronavirus
has
so the idea is your body makes all these
spike proteins
if you get the live virus in you the
body
recognizes that protein because the mrna
vaccine
already told the body how to make it it
doesn't make you sick because it quickly
quickly dispatches with the real virus
okay where they get it's not a vaccine
is that it is not a weakened or
deactivated virus
that is triggering your body to make the
spike protein it is
messenger rna mrna triggering your body
to make the spike protein that doesn't
mean it's not a vaccine
it's merely a different method of
achieving the same thing
so it's not experimental it is a vaccine
it's not a gene therapy and it doesn't
alter your dna
everything steve bannon says is untrue
now let's continue to another piece of
the clip
which is equally lie riddled take a look
at this
they're going to get to a part a point
very quickly
if you don't have the vaccine you're not
going to get the vaccine passport
and if in other words you're not going
to be able to get on a plane you're not
going to be able to get on public
transportation
basically you're not going to be able to
hold a job okay and yet they don't want
any debate whatsoever not from people
that are anti-vaxxers but people just
have legitimate hey can you walk me
through this again what
what phase of this is really in testing
it's got emergency
authorized use by the fda so now he goes
into it will be mandatory vaccination as
evidenced by an airline might say if you
want to fly with us you need a vaccine
certificate
or live nation or ticketmaster or
whoever might say if you want to come to
a concert at one of our venues for which
we sell tickets
you need a vaccine certificate first of
all that's not the government making
anything mandatory
and it's not the government doing
anything at all those are private
companies
second is steve bannon saying that the
government gets to tell private
companies
you can't require proof of vaccination
is that
i mean the these are small government
free market conservatives
who seem to want it to be made illegal
by the government
for a private company to say we
if you want to avail yourself of our
product or service
we require you to show proof of
vaccination if requiring vaccination
is bad for like imagine delta or jetblue
says
you know after september 1 after january
1 you need to be vaccinated to fly with
us which they haven't done by the way
maybe they would
if they do that and it's a bad business
idea the market will punish them
because all of the unvaccinated people
who want to fly
will switch from delta or jetblue to
some airline that doesn't require a
vaccine
that's the market well what if every
airline requires a vaccine
then the free market has created an
opportunity for a
new airline to come in and take all the
customers
that want to fly without being
vaccinated that's how right wingers
sell us on the magic and deficiency
and perfection of free markets and yet
now
they're using yes conspiracy theories
that aren't going to become a thing
to i guess argue for the exact opposite
which would be very heavy-handed
regulation by a government
they tend to claim shouldn't be involved
in regulating private industry unless
absolutely and completely necessary
these people are not just pathetic
but they're spreading dangerous
conspiracy theories
that reduce the number of people who
might want the vaccine
and it's getting it's like whack-a-mole
it's getting harder and harder in fact i
even have
i i even if as a visual aid i even have
my uh
my gavel it is like playing whack-a-mole
here trying to
uh tamp down all of these different
conspiracy theories and steve bannon's
certainly not uh
not making any easier we will have more
coverage of this
and other vaccine-related conspiracy
theories
on our instagram at davidpakmanshow and
you can follow me on instagram as well
at david.pakman
one of our sponsors purevpn is giving
you 47 percent off
a one-year plan which comes out to less
than six bucks a month
purevpn makes you anonymous online and
you can trust them they're the only vpn
with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity
is not being logged purevpn keeps you
safe from hackers prevents you from
being spied on by your isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week
for just 99 cents and you'll get 47
percent off
a one year plan which is less than six
bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman